This is a hard conversation.
I want to start with that.
Well, let's step into it.
It was 1977.
Jimmy Carter was president.
"Queen" was playing on the radio.
I was having lunch in my high school
cafeteria in Houston, Texas,
when we heard a young man shouting
at another young man next to him saying,
“You stole my girlfriend,
and I’m going to make you pay.”
He pulled out a pistol,
and as about 100 of us looked on,
he shot and killed him.
Two years later,
I was a freshman, big state university,
Friday night in the dorm room.
Music, beer,
five young men take a young woman
back to one of their rooms
and force her to have sex.
There was no investigation at the time.
No one called it rape.
No one said sexual violence.
These two events are
what drove me to do this work.
I work with survivors
of violence around the world.
It was somehow easier to work
with survivors in other parts
than it was to think about this
in my own country, the US.
And in that work,
a throughline became clear.
And that throughline is manhood.
It is an inconvenient
and difficult-to-look-at truth,
but the majority of violence
in the world is carried out by men.
Since that shooting in my high school,
at least 800,000 people have died
from gun suicide in the US alone.
The vast majority of those, men.
About 600,000 people have died
of homicide in the US alone.
The vast majority of those
who did the killing were men.
One in three women in the world
experiences violence from a male partner.
Violence is overwhelmingly male.
Often, the point will come up,
this must be biology.
Yes, biology accounts
for a small portion of it,
but the vast majority
is how we raise boys.
Research that we do --
(Applause)
Research that we've carried out
finds that about --
and we ask this in multiple countries --
about two thirds of men tell us
that during childhood they experienced
physical violence from another male.
You do not get to adult manhood
in most of the world without experiencing,
witnessing and learning male violence.
Now, when I bring these points up,
several things often happen.
One is someone will say,
well, you're attacking men.
Someone will also say, well,
you're apologizing for men as you look
at these origins of violence.
We've got to talk about this.
We have to understand what are these
pathways to men's use of violence
if we're to break
these cycles of violence.
This conversation must be
about the version of manhood
we literally beat in to boys.
My organization, Equimundo, does research
around the world on these topics.
We listen to men, we carry out research
together with the UN,
country governments, local partners.
We've been measuring
over the last 10 to 12 years
where men are on these
versions of manhood.
This won't surprise you,
as we look at some of the numbers.
About 40 to 50 percent of men in the world
believe in a version of manhood
that goes like this:
I’ve got to outperform
the other at all cost.
I can’t show that I’m vulnerable
or ask for help.
That sex is about conquest,
not about intimacy and connection.
That you’ve got to show
that you’re tough all the time.
And that violence is a reasonable
way to get what you want.
These are not just empty phrases.
These are things that men talk about.
They create realities.
The other thing we find is
that the more you believe in these norms,
these ideas about manhood,
you are multiple times
more likely to do this:
to have considered suicide,
to use violence against others,
to harm yourself
and to harm others in multiple ways.
These norms affect us, they cause harm.
Now I realize I'm doing
in that last affirmation
something that I said
I wasn't going to do in this talk,
which is women know this.
And when a man explains to women
something they already know,
we have a word for that.
I'm not going to do that.
(Laughter)
I'm not going to do that, OK?
Pull that back.
What I do want is to get men
talking about this.
So call this “mansplaining to men.”
(Applause)
Thank you for that,
because I don't get a lot of men
inviting me to the bar
when I have these
conversations, so thank you.
Thank you for that love.
What I do often bring up with men,
and you could see why they find me
kind of inconvenient to have around,
is I'll say, men, we die, on average,
six years earlier than women in the US.
Around the rest of the world,
pretty similar numbers.
Why is that?
Part of that's biology, we know this.
The female body is a better model.
(Laughter)
(Cheers and applause)
Let us acknowledge that.
The vast majority of this, though,
is how we live as men.
What we drink,
what we smoke, how we drive,
the harm we put ourselves in the way of,
the drugs that we take,
how we literally live as men.
Of course it interacts with racism,
with where you live, with poverty,
but we're literally dying of manhood.
Women pick up the pieces
when men die early.
They are the ones who do the care,
who carry on households,
who carry on in countries when men die.
This affects us all.
My daughter, when she was 12, 13,
middle school, she said,
"Dad, girls are talking a lot
about empowered womanhood
and how we can be in the world.
But the boys seem kind of lost.
Could you come and give a talk
at school about this?"
(Laughter)
So, for better or worse,
I started with this example.
The boys' eyes were going up,
"Wait, I never thought about the fact
that I could die on average earlier
than women because of all these reasons."
Next day I get a letter,
a note from one of the boys
who gave it to my daughter to give to me,
and I opened it up and it said,
“Dear Dr. Barker,
thank you for that information.
I never thought about how we as men
are affected by these things.
Only now, I'm worried about dying."
(Laughter)
(Exhales sharply)
I am a developmental psychologist,
and I should know a little bit more
than having a 12-year-old think
about his own mortality.
(Laughter)
Trying to get some help for that myself.
The point was, he got it.
And that is what we need
men to think about.
This pathway is how to step into
how we as men are part
of this conversation
and how we benefit from it.
OK, risk of mansplaining here.
You know where men are having these
conversations if we don't talk to them.
Young men right now are having
these conversations online.
There is an explosion of conversations
about manhood online.
Some of them are good.
How much water to drink,
the exercise you should carry out,
how can I get close to somebody
I'm interested in.
That’s guys trying to be
their best selves.
But there’s a huge amount of it
that’s fed by an industry
of misogynist and angry influencers
who are getting
the attention of young men.
Our research finds that 40 to 50
percent of young men in the US
say they trust one or more
of those negative voices online.
Why are they going there?
They are lost,
they are struggling, they're confused.
Other data that we have,
almost 50 percent of men in the US
say they think about suicide frequently.
About two thirds of young men tell us
that "no one really knows me."
What a call and a cry
about loneliness in their lives.
If we don't reach out, they will continue
to find solace online
with the voices that we well know about.
For young men of color,
these issues are even more acute.
Job uncertainties, education,
systemic racism.
One young man that we worked
with in Washington, DC,
when he was part of a training activity
to carry out work in schools,
as we're going through the training
of trainers, he said,
"Gary, these ideas of manhood
that you talk about,
for a white guy like you,
it's like the flu.
For me as a Black guy,
this is pneumonia."
I think that's an excellent
point to think about,
the compassion that we have to step into
as we have this conversation.
And this is where I want
to take the last point here.
We have to talk about care.
Care of boys, care about boys,
care for men,
and talk to boys
and men about how they care.
Let me talk a little bit more about that.
One of the casualties that we face
as men growing up in that version
of manhood that I presented to you,
is that we make this thick
shell around ourselves.
We close off our emotions,
we close ourselves off
to the human connection we need.
Think about what young men frequently say.
I would guess, I don't know
that we've asked it in a survey,
but one of the most frequent things
that young men say,
"I don't care."
It is our perfect shell, right?
We close ourselves behind it,
and it also says, you can't shame me,
you can't question me, you can't hurt me,
you can't embarrass me
because I don't care.
I said it thousands of times
as a teenage boy.
I'm sure my mother would have
a bigger number.
And I know I've said it thousands
of times as an adult man as well.
This is the shield that we put on
to close ourselves off.
The conversation that we need
to step into with boys
is not about their mortality,
but it is about how we care.
Where I start that conversation
is to think about our
superpower as humans.
We are the most wired-to-care
species on the planet.
Our neurological systems,
our hormonal systems,
are wired to care, to nurture, to love,
to form attachments with others.
But it's not automatic.
If you don't use it,
if you close it off, if you hide,
you don't get good at it.
But if you try and if you practice
and if you learn it,
you do get good at it.
Even the man who seems most cut off
from the world can learn it.
I take you back to my high school in 1977.
The boy who killed the other.
I didn't tell you this part,
but I knew him.
Took me years to say
I didn't know him well
because I didn't want to know him well.
He got detention, he bullied,
he got detention again,
he didn't do well in school,
he got sent away.
No one, apparently, reached out to him.
Think about what we often do
when boys or men cause harm.
If you're young,
we give you a time out.
Get a little bit older,
we give you a detention.
You step into the workplace,
you do harm, we fire you.
You do something else, we incarcerate you.
These acts are often necessary
to reduce harm,
but they cut men off from the connection
and humanity that we need,
even when men have caused harm.
I am not, in saying this,
I'm not affirming or believing
that we should give any man a free walk
for harm that is caused.
We must hold men
accountable for harm caused.
No question about that.
We must call out with deep compassion
when men do cause harm.
We've also got to call in
to being connected, caring humans.
This is not instead of,
and I think this is very
important to end on,
this is not instead of the unfinished
journey for full equality,
respect and rights that every woman
and girl on the planet deserves.
(Applause)
This is an "and" conversation.
We must continue that journey
and we must talk about manhood.
And I also believe that it is this
conversation about pulling men into care
that we get them to be allies
for gender equality.
(Applause)
My final point would be this:
look at the face of any
three-year-old boy on the planet.
He was not born into the world
to be angry, aggressive,
to follow dark threads down the internet.
He comes into the world ready to be
loved and to learn how to love.
Take him, talk to him,
teach him every day: I care.
Thank you.
(Applause)